virus drehen sollen wir schauen aber
auch auf die aktuellen entwicklungen
hier in deutschland und in europa
niemand sei verzichtbar es komme jetzt
auf alle an sagt die bundeskanzlerin in
ihrer ansprache an die nation
sie warb für verständnis für alle
einschränkenden maßnahmen weitere
einschränkungen soll es aber erst mal
nicht geben
deutschland im stresstest die ganze
gesellschaft wird wird herausgefordert
und natürlich steht auch die aktuelle
regierung unter immensen druck
insbesondere die kanzlerin
nicole diekmann über das politische
berlin in außergewöhnlichen zeiten das
kabinett heute vormittag bilder die
normalität in die verunsicherte republik
senden sollen aber statt im
kabinettssaal des kanzleramts trifft man
sich in größeren internationalen
konferenzsaal
so soll abstand gewahrt bleiben woran
sich noch nicht alle halten
zwei minister fehlen finanzminister
scholz schrieb auf facebook er sei
erkältet und lasse sich vorsorglich auf
grüner testen und auch
bildungsministerin carlitscheck arbeitet
momentan von zu hause aus ihr team
twittert die ministerin habe kontakt zu
rainer corona positiven person gehabt
auch äußerst ungewöhnlich eine video
ansprache von angela merkel
es kommt auf jeden an
wir sind nicht verdammt die ausbreitung
des virus passiv hinzunehmen wir haben
einen mittel dagegen
wir müssen aus rücksicht voneinander
abstand halten
der rat der virologen ist ja eindeutig
kein handschlag mehr gründlich und oft
die hände waschen mindestens eineinhalb
meter abstand zum nächsten und am besten
kaum noch kontakte zu den ganz alten
weil sie eben besonders gefährdet sind
eine regierungschefin die sich mit von
experten seit wochen mantraartig
geäußerten ratschlägen an das volk
wendet ganz offensichtlich ist das nötig
denn auch das ist berlin
abstand halten möglichst zu hause
bleiben um die ausweitung des virus zu
verlangsamen davon keine spur
noch versucht man ausgangssperren wie
heute in einer bayerischen kleinstadt
verhängt landesweit zu vermeiden
beim genauen hinhören wird aber klar sie
könnten komme ich ab
ihre an sie halten sie sich an die
regeln
die nun für die nächste zeit gelten wir
werden als regierung stets neu prüfen
was sich wieder korrigieren lässt aber
auch was für möglich noch nötig ist
in den vergangenen tagen trat merkel
mehrfach vor die presse nachdem ihr in
der flüchtlingskrise vorgeworfen worden
war
ihre politik zu wenig zu erklären jetzt
kommunikationsoffensive das echo der
opposition auf die videobotschaft von
heute gemischt wir erleben große
wirtschaftliche verwerfungen in den
nächsten wochen und monaten da muss
konkret gehandelt werden appelle allein
reichen nicht aus die kanzlerin führt
nicht sie reagiert wieder und sie sagt
nicht wie es weitergeht richtig ist aber
dass frau merkel jetzt die bürgerinnen
und bürger alle in die pflicht nimmt uns
alle in die pflicht nimmt die korona
krise sei die größte herausforderung
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg sagte merkel
die situation ernst und offen berlin
weiter im zeichen des virus mit sich
verschärfender tonart robert habe
bundesvorsitzender von bündnis 90/die
grünen ist uns zugeschaltet guten abend
guten abend
er habe die kanzlerin hat sich an die
nation gewendet was war für sie die
wichtigste botschaft und hat ihnen das
gereicht das war dringlich erforderlich
dass wir diese rede an die nation
gehalten hat es war gut und richtig und
wichtig dass sie heute gehalten hat mir
hat der ton gefallen er war unaufgeregt
er war präzise der appell dass wir alle
aktiv sein können nicht in dieser
passivität versinken das war auch
richtig und das verbot und besonders
richtig und wichtig auch für die zukunft
finde ich dass sie das fenster für
abwägungen aufgemacht hat sie hat ja
gesagt die maßnahmen werden überprüft
sie können zurückgenommen werden
es können weitere dazukommen das
bedeutet wir müssen miteinander
diskutieren was ist richtig und auch
eine fehlertoleranz entwickeln und ich
will für mich und für uns zu sagen dass
wir genau das machen wollen bei neuen
maßnahmen richtig sind und wir erkennen
eine zehnte vielleicht nicht ganz
und die wird zurückgenommen oder sie
wird verschärft dann wird man nicht
sagen wie könnt ihr nur sondern genau
wir sind im
genau das muss jetzt gemacht werden das
war gut dass sie das fenster aufgemacht
hat für diese form von debatte sie haben
die maßnahmen angesprochen in den
letzten tagen kamen ja immer wieder
kritik die maßnahmen in deutschland
kennen zu zögerlich die zuständigkeiten
seien nicht eindeutig es gebe kein
gemeinsames vorgehen
diese kritik haben von unterschiedlichen
seiten von der opposition hat man
dagegen wenig gehört sind sie zufrieden
mit der regierung
na ja wir sind ja nicht nur opposition
und wenn wir opposition sind im
bundestag beispielsweise begreifen wir
uns schon als teil des gesamtstaatlichen
verantwortungsgefühl ist dass wir gerade
haben aber wir haben
gesundheitsministerin finanzministerin
wir haben wirtschaftsminister
wir haben die ministerpräsidenten wir
sind permanent die haben die ganzen
kommunalpolitiker wir sind ja teil der
umsetzung der bekämpfung der korona
krise richtig ist dass muss man sagen
dass die das der anfang ein bisschen
holprig war das teilweise aussagen
widersprüchlich waren erst dieses
grenzschließung brauchen wir nicht von
den gesundheitsexperten dann war es doch
notwendig also da waren ein paar fragen
und man war nicht ganz auf sicherem
boden und ich glaube dass die
bundeskanzlerin heute mit der ansage
geschaffen transparenz darüber genau das
richtige getan hat wenn es
meinungsänderung gibt wenn maßnahmen die
davor als nicht wirksam betrachtet
wurden auf einmal doch wirksam sind dann
muss erläutert werden und deswegen war
es gut dass frau merkel heute vor die
kameras getreten ist sie hat damals
verantwortung gezeigt verantwortung
übernommen und ist in die verantwortung
gegangen
aber inwieweit werden sie in diese
entscheidungsprozesse eingebunden wie
kann sich das ganz praktisch vorstellen
das läuft so dass auf der exekutiven
ebene also ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
und die wirtschaftsminister miteinander
jeweils mit dem kondom mit dem
wirtschaftsminister oder die
finanzminister in permanenten telefon
schaltungen sind live trifft sich
eigentlich niemand mehr
und dann übersetzung in die anderen
gliederungen von parteien erfolgt also
wenn kretschmann mit der kanzlerin
gesprochen hat dann informiert der frau
berbalk und mich nicht regelmäßig und
nicht permanent aber wir sind eher
dauerndem kontakt so dass wir eigentlich
immer wissen was passiert unsere fragen
stellen die fragen wiederum bei anderen
ankommen und so verästelt sich dann
sozusagen das verantwortungsgefühl in
die parteien hinein ganz kurzen noch
eine letzte frage krisen verändern ja
gesellschaften und sicher auch das
politische handeln in der zukunft eher
eine chance oder eher eine gefahr für
sie ja es ist offen also ich kann nicht
ausschließen dass wir nach der korona
krise im eine in ein populismus
verfallen ist die demokratie der
föderalismus europa leistungsfähig und
sind wir gut durch die krise durch
gekommen ich hoffe und ich glaube daran
müssen wir jetzt arbeiten dass genau das
gegenteil der fall ist dass wir jetzt
schon erkennen dass kooperation
solidarität und zwar europäische
kooperation und solidarität die richtige
antwort ist und dass eine demokratie in
der form der transparenz die dinge offen
zu diskutieren miteinander die richtige
antwort ist sicher ist das nicht aber da
nicht ganz mit der bundeskanzlerin dafür
zu streiten und sich das klar zu machen
dass ich jetzt das gebot der stunde und
habe vielen dank in den letzten tagen
haben wir unseren blick vor allem auf
deutschland gerichtet und klar erstmal
standen auch für uns die entwicklungen
hier im land und ihre ganz persönlichen
fragen an erster stelle
interessant ist aber gerade auch jetzt
der blick nach brüssel wäre dieser
ausnahmezustand nicht die chance mit
einer stimme zu sprechen gemeinsam in
der eu entscheidungen zu treffen
wir sehen jedes land beschließt
unterschiedliche maßnahmen gehören jedes
land beurteilt die lage anders
und viele denken wäre es nicht dringend
nötig diese krise europäisch anzugehen
anne gellinek mit ihrem blick auf europa
das motiv ist die lehre brüssels
berühmteste sehenswürdigkeit die
mittelalterliche grund platz wie
ausgestorben wo sich normalerweise
morgens mittags abends touristen
schieben jetzt polizei patrouillieren
seit 12 uhr heute mittag hat ganz
belgien hausarrest alle müssen drin
bleiben ausnahmen für notwendige
besorgungen sind erlaubt blumen gehören
nicht dazu
der flur ist versucht seine ware noch
schnell loszuwerden und fügt sich die
regierung hat diese entscheidung
getroffen sie hat getan was sie tun
musste so sind die zeiten nun mal auch
das europaviertel leergefegt tausende
mitarbeiter der europäischen
institutionen sitzen im home-office die
chefs in videokonferenzen oder am
telefon was bei exit und eurokrise nicht
geschafft haben
gelingt nun dem virus die eu fällt
auseinander
im angesicht der krise brücke der
zusammenhalt unter den mitgliedsstaaten
deutlichstes zeichen sind die
grenzkontrollen kilometerlange lkw staus
wie hier an der polnisch litauischen
grenze 10 von 26 schengen staaten
darunter deutschland österreich polen
und spanien haben die schlagbäume wieder
gesenkt jeder ist sich selbst der
nächste
die zeichen stehen auf abschottung die
eu-kommission stolpert den
grenzschließungen hinterher sie kann nur
empfehlen ein flehentlicher appell wir
erwarten dass die mitgliedstaaten im
geiste von zusammenarbeit und
solidarität unsere empfehlungen umsetzen
das ist wichtig auch für jene eu bürger
die zum teil in anderen eu-ländern
gestrandet sind und nach hause wollen
[Musik]
wie zum beispiel an der eu binnengrenzen
zwischen österreich und ungarn bei
nickelsdorf rumänen und bulgaren aber
auch ukraine haben der korona krise
wegen ihre jobs in italien verloren und
stecken nun auf dem nachhauseweg fest
ein 30 kilometer stau hat sich gebildet
erst nach zähen verhandlungen lassen die
ungarn einige fahrzeuge passieren
wir sind aber dabei
die situation professionell abzuarbeiten
das heißt versuchen deeskalierend
einzuwirken bzw auch versuchen wir
derzeit auch die versorgung der menschen
sicherzustellen längst überwunden
geglaubte reflexe sind wieder da
misstrauen staus grenzen
die korona krise hat europa verändert
vielleicht für eine lange zeit zurück
nach deutschland hier haben bund und
länder gestern einen notfallplan für
krankenhäuser beschlossen das ziel ist
klar kapazitäten erhöhen krankenhäuser
entlasten oder anders gesagt das
gesundheitssystem wird vorbereitet auf
die notfallversorgung viele patientinnen
und patienten während die einen kliniken
sich auf den ausbau von intensivbetten
konzentrieren sollen werden in
spezialkliniken und auch an anderen auch
ungewöhnlichen orten zusätzliche
kapazitäten geschaffen in
schönheitskliniken zum beispiel reha
zentren und großen hallen sollen dann
auch menschen medizinisch behandelt
werden
eine maßnahme die es seit dem kriegsende
in deutschland so auch noch nicht gab
susan von neuem ski und allersberg
wissen wie sich das klinikum stuttgart
auf den ernstfall vorbereitet ein petit
roboter ist im normalen leben vielleicht
nicht von entscheidender bedeutung jetzt
gibt er aber womöglich lebens wichtige
hinweise
mit minimalem personalaufwand kann er
800 proben am tag auf das proma virus
untersuchen
im klinikum stuttgart testen sie jetzt
24 7 zeit und menge das ist genau das
was sie an krankenhäusern jetzt dringend
brauchen zeit um sich vorzubereiten auf
schwerstkranke auf einen anstieg
hilfsbedürftiger auf den ernstfall
die vorbereitungen laufen seit wochen
werden stationen freigeräumt zunächst
eine mittlerweile drei haben seit heute
eine intensivstation freigeräumt
die wir vorbereiten wir trainieren
personal wir haben ablaufpläne
aktualisiert für die isolation üben das
material aufgestockt vorräte an
schutzkleidung deutlich erhöht professor
jürgen sind ist chef des klinikums
stuttgart tausende ärzte 2700
pflegekräfte ein ganzes gebäude hat ja
schon räumen und isolieren lassen die
hälfte aller geplanten operationen wurde
abgesagt jetzt ist anderes wichtiger
wir versuchen stabile teams zu schaffen
und möglichst die zahl der personen die
mit infizierten in kontakt kommen gering
zu halten die auch gut zu trainieren
eingespielte teams zu haben
so verlangen wir verschiedene quarantäne
stationen für die das schwerpunktmäßig
gilt das heißt aber auch dass wir
umsortieren andere station frei ziehen
verdichten und durch die reduktion
programm zurück fahren im klartext heißt
das die mitarbeiter müssen flexibel sein
und sind es in der tumor testung der
kinderonkologie etwa in der im moment
nicht so viel los ist werden jetzt wie
ihren analysen per hand gemacht
an den beatmungsgeräten wird das
medizinische personal aus allen
abteilungen noch einmal geschult
schwerstkranke sollen jetzt das am
besten geeignete personal bekommen wer
nicht ganz so schlimme symptome hat wird
möglicherweise von fachkräften anderer
stationen betreut
schon jetzt liegen hier schwer kranke
menschen auch corona infizierte
noch aber sind sie hier entschlossen den
kampf gegen die zeit zu gewinnen sind
konzentriert
fokussiert noch nicht besorgt aber es
sicherlich eine ernste lage
wie ernst die lage ist zeigt sich vor
der tür
hier wird die schlange der menschen die
getestet werden müssen immer länger
seit heute werden abstriche nur noch bei
denen mit starken symptomen oder bei
chronisch kranken gemacht dass sich das
virus zu schnell verbreitet das ist hier
die größte sorge von fachpersonal
mangeln könnte beziehungsweise sehr hohe
belastung auf die fachkräfte dann zu
kommen das sieht er als nadelöhr als die
tatsächlichen intensiv plätze und
beatmungsgeräte auf der intensivstation
richten sie derweil zusätzliche zimmer
ein
im schlimmsten fall kann man von bisher
80 intensivbetten auf das doppelte
erhöhen
gestern lagen noch vier corona
infizierte in der klinik heute sind es
schon zehn in berlin begrüße ich jetzt
den präsidenten der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft professor gerald
gaß guten abend gut' abend was ist aus
ihrer sicht für die ärzteschaft jetzt
die größte herausforderung wie wird es
gelingen diesen notfallplan wirklich
umzusetzen
ja für uns alle in den krankenhäusern
ist die größte herausforderung sich
jetzt gezielt und strukturiert auf die
vor uns liegende lage vorzubereiten und
der bericht den sie aus stuttgart
gesehen haben zeigt dass wir alle mit
unglaublichem engagement an die sache
gehen seit vielen wochen versuchen wir
die kapazitäten zu erweitern das ist an
vielen standorten auch bereits gelungen
wir kennen unsere verantwortung und wir
wissen dass es auf die krankenhäuser
ankommt wenn jetzt viele schwerkranke
patientinnen und patienten bei uns
erscheinen werden
und wie so oft in den letzten tagen die
frage nach dem zeitpunkt hätte dieser
notfallplan nicht auch schon früher
umgesetzt werden können oder müssen
wir haben ja ende des vergangenen jahres
im dezember in china die ersten
entwicklungen gesehen die virologen
haben das analysiert und bereits mitte
januar sind die krankenhäuser auf den
plan gerufen worden
wir haben unsere pandemiepläne die ja
allgemein vorgehalten werden
aktualisiert wir haben unsere
bevorratung aufgestockt und wir haben
das getan was möglich war ich glaube
nicht dass man früher hätte beginnen
können
professor ist danke fürs erste
besprechen gleich nochmal weiter denn
nicht nur für krankenhäuser auch für
arztpraxen und pflegeheime könnte sich
die situation in den nächsten tagen
deutlich zuspitzen vor zwei wochen schon
fehlt eine schutzbekleidung manche
ärztinnen und ärzte klagen über
mangelnde informationen fühlten sich
alleingelassen zwischenzeitlich
entspannte sich wieder die situation so
war unser eindruck
viele praxen es stellten sich schnell
auf die neue lage ein die
informationsketten funktionierten etwas
besser und jetzt wir sind pflegerinnen
pfleger ärztinnen und ärzte auf die
nächsten tage vorbereitet ein blick auf
die lage in der stadt und auf dem land
bad vilbel in hessen hausarzt praxis dr
ansgar schultheis bislang hatte er nur
einen patienten der positiv auf das
corona virus getestet wurde
doch in diesem glück im unglück gehabt
das war alles richtig gemacht haben den
patienten vor der sprechstunde
einbestellt mit mundschutz handschuhen
getestet und den patienten gleich wieder
nach hause geschickt von daher glaube
ich haben wir alles richtig gemacht und
stehe und kontakten im gesundheitsamt so
das glaube ich der praxis betrieb
weitergehen kann
aus sicherheitsgründen macht schulter
ist keinen corona test mehr
wir versuchen alle patienten die als
risikopatienten einstufen direkt an
diese testzentren zu vermitteln und
patienten die wir eben nicht als als
risikopatienten einstufen die trotzdem
auch in fact zeichen haben versuchen wir
eben telefonisch zu behandeln
an normalen tagen kommen bis zu 250
patienten in die gemeinschaftspraxis mit
vier ärzten an diesem tag sind es nur
gut ein dutzend zum arzt geht nur wer
wirklich muss
die schmerzen weniger patienten aber das
risiko sich anzustecken bleibt und
dagegen muss sich das praxispersonal
schützen seine größte sorge schutzmasken
handschuhe und desinfektionsmittel gehen
langsam aus
ich glaube eigentlich stehen alle
arztpraxen in deutschland mit
runtergelassenen hosen da weil eben weil
es an allen an jeglichem schutzlack
widmen fehlt wenn jetzt eine praxis
schließt glaube ich können die anderen
das noch ganz gut auffangen aber die
frage ist ja wie viele praxen müssen
jetzt in zukunft noch schließen eben
wenn corona fälle in der praxis waren
ich habe jetzt von zwei praxen gehört
die geschlossen wurden bei leben da
ungeschützter kontakt verstand und die
jeweiligen jetzt in quarantäne sind
lieferengpässe sind realität praxis
kollege dr walter zeigt die letzten
bestände ihrer desinfektionsmittel
damit hätte er vor der korona krise nie
gerechnet gefördert insoweit im stich
gelassen
das ist tatsächlich keinerlei
unterstützung keinerlei vorratshaltung
gibt um die praxen damit zu versorgen um
die grundversorgung letztlich
aufrechtzuerhalten thüringen erfurt in
dieser gemeinschaftspraxis wurden zwei
teams gebildet ein arzt und helferteam
bleiben eine woche zu hause dann wird
gewechselt so soll der langfristige
praxisbetrieb gesichert werden mit einer
speziellen kroner sprechstunden werden
auch die patienten getrennt wir haben
also eine infekt sprechstunde jeden tag
von 12 bis 14 uhr eingerichtet in der
ausschließlich infekt patienten
behandelt werden und in der übrigen zeit
ausschließlich nicht infektiösen
patienten das wird auch so kommuniziert
und auch sehr gut akzeptiert von den
patienten ein kleiner vorrat an masken
handschuhe und desinfektionsmittel ist
noch vorhanden aber auch hier ist ein
ende absehbar probleme sieht die ärztin
ein ganz anderer stelle was ich wirklich
mit sorge sehe das sind unsere alten
patientin dem wir ganz ganz schlecht
motivieren können sich an
die vorsichtsmassnahmen zu halten und
ein weiteres problem auch bei
medikamenten wird gehamstert zunehmend
sehen wir jetzt gestern und heute uns
mit patienten konfrontiert die versuchen
sich zu bevorraten mit ihren
medikamenten
das kann man natürlich auch nur in engen
grenzen kann man eben nur stadt geben
und wir sehen jetzt auch immer mehr
angst panik um nicht zu sagen hysterie
bei bei patienten die vielleicht gar
nicht zu einer risikogruppe gehören es
sehr sehr viel aufklärungsarbeit
erforderlich drk blutspendedienst in
erfurt fieber messen und desinfektion
bei der ankunft neue
sicherheitsvorkehrungen
also haben wir von vornherein sehr hohen
standards die wir dadurch jetzt
natürlich noch einmal ein stück weit
aufgewertet haben und wir rufen wir auch
die leute auf wäre wer sich gesund fühlt
und fit fühlt der sollte lieber
blutspenden und leute die sie leichtes
unwohlsein namen oder auch im schnupfen
touristen möglichst fern zu bleiben die
bereitschaft blut zu spenden ist zwar
rückläufig dieser tage aber im moment
ist da jetzt keine panik angesagt aber
wir müssen natürlich schauen von tag zu
tag von woche zu woche wie sich das
entwickelt werden ungewisse zeiten
abarbeiten auf sicht fahren wie auch in
der praxis von doktor schultheiß hat es
an vorbereitung an planung gemangelt für
ihn ist die antwort darauf jetzt erst
einmal unwichtig für den arzt zählt nur
eins den praxisbetrieb für seine
patienten aufrecht zu erhalten
noch mal an sie gerichtet die frage
professor gas zu wenige schutzmasken zu
wenig desinfektionsmittel all die
probleme kennen sie ja auch aus den
krankenhäusern aus dem letzten wochen
wie kann das passieren
die lieferketten die vom weltmarkt
normalerweise bedient werden waren seit
mitte januar unterbrochen auch wir als
kliniken hatten keine chance mehr noch
beliefert zu werden lediglich das
material was schon auf dem weg war aus
asien ist angekommen und deshalb sind
wir tatsächlich darauf angewiesen dass
bund und länder zentral beschaffen neue
lieferwege aufmachen
das ist auch erfolg und wir hatten heute
nachmittag einen termin im
bundesgesundheitsministerium wo uns
zugesagt wurde noch bis ende der woche
wird die logistik stehen um die
verteilung dann in die kliniken zu
organisieren die in erster linie jetzt
mit
ihren vorräten fast schon am ende sind
aber ich bin sehr zuversichtlich dass
wir dann ausreichend material für die
kommenden tage und wochen auch haben
werden aber das nicht auch was damit zu
tun dass lange zeit viele politikern
auch experten gesagt haben naja ist
nicht so schlimm
extremen maßnahmen seien
unverhältnismäßig alles mit maß und um
sich sollte passieren
also müssen nicht jetzt ärzte und
krankenhäuser das ausbaden weil viele
die gefahr dass wir es kommt doch
unterschätzt haben ich glaube das ist
schwierig jetzt zu beurteilen und jetzt
der politik oder anderen vorwürfe zu
machen ich denke das war eine sehr
dynamische lage die wir vor uns hatten
und auch viele experten haben jeden tag
dazugelernt das gilt auch für die
krankenhäuser gilt auch für die anderen
experten und wir haben uns sehr schnell
dann auf die neue situation eingestellt
man wird hinterher beurteilen ob es gut
ist besser vorbereitet zu sein im
hinblick auf das thema bevorratung ich
bin froh dass deutschland so viele
krankenhäuser und so viele standorte hat
und insofern eine gute basis für die
jetzt kommenden tage und wochen
wir haben das in unseren sendungen den
letzten tagen immer wieder gespürt viele
menschen machen sich sorgen dass es auch
bei uns zustände wie in italienischen
krankenhäusern geben könnte sind jetzt
so aufgestellt dass dies nicht mehr
passieren kann
wir hatten vor der dramatischen
situation die wir in italien erleben in
deutschland schon im regelsystem 28.000
intensivbetten und 20.000 beatmungs
plätze
das ist die vierfache menge dessen an
der bevölkerungsdichte gemessen was
italien hatte und wir haben in den
letzten tagen diese zahl nochmals
deutlich aufgestockt wir planen
tatsächlich die intensiv kapazitäten
nahezu zu verdoppeln das wird eine
gewisse zeit dauern aber wir sind besser
vorbereitet das ist gut so und wir
werden nicht so schnell an die grenzen
kommen wie in italien
doch entscheidend ist und das hat die
kanzlerin vorhin ja betont dass die
infektionsketten durchbrochen werden
dass nicht zu viele patienten
gleichzeitig in den krankenhäusern
ankommen letzte frage viele menschen
machen sich jetzt auch sorgen dass
geplante operationen die auch
dies sind für viele langfristig
verschoben werden ändert sich mit den
neuen kapazitäten in den krankenhäusern
daran was in der tat ja wir haben seit
dem wochenende begonnen und jetzt am
montag noch intensiver die kapazitäten
vorzuhalten für die ankommenden
patienten das heißt wir haben planbare
leistungen verschoben brand planbare
operationen dort wird aber sehr
verantwortlich umgegangen das heißt
nicht jeder patient der eine operation
vor sich hatte muss darauf verzichten
oder wird verschoben sondern es wird
medizinisch beurteilt ob eine
schwerwiegende erkrankung vorliegt und
dann wird selbstverständlich auch
behandelt sagt der präsident der
deutschen krankenhausgesellschaft
professor gas vielen dank gerne liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer jetzt
kommen wir noch mal zu den fragen die
wir heute im laufe des tages
eingesammelt haben
sie werden nicht weniger und besonders
die fragen nach ansteckungsgefahr und
verhalten beschäftigen viele menschen
die antworten kommen heute von professor
produktleiter vom uniklinikum mainz
schönen guten abend
wir legen gleich los mit zuschauerfragen
schauen sie mal ja ich bin schwanger
es dauert nicht mehr lange und demnächst
werde ich also ins krankenhaus müssen
auf jeden fall zur entbindung und da
frage ich mich natürlich jetzt auch
wie läuft das ganze ab bin nicht der
optimal versorgt und kann diese
versorgung auch gewährleistet werden
innerhalb der nächsten zwei drei wochen
wir haben zwar schon ein hohes alter
erreichen wir stehen beide kurz vor 80
aber wir sind durch die betreuung von
unserer haus sind sehr gut betreut und
zwar in puncto impfung wir sind geimpft
gegen zecken wir sind wir und gegen
keuchhusten wir sind gegen die imk gegen
lungenentzündung und man hat schon oft
als gehört dass wenn man diese impfungen
hat das verhindert zwar die krankheit
nicht aber der verlauf ist gering stimmt
diese aussage oder ist das falsch herr
professor also schwenger schwangere
ältere risikogruppen wir haben gehört
von einem älteren mann der geimpft ist
müssen die sich sorgen machen jetzt
zunächst mal sagen vielleicht natürlich
ist es so dass war gibt während die
operationen oder für maßnahmen nicht
durchgeführt werden aber natürlich wird
die normale betrieben natürlich auch die
entsprechende geburtshilfe weiter
funktionieren also da muss man
sicherlich keine sorgen machen
zum anderen frage jetzt bezüglich der
impfungen
die sind natürlich hilfreich weil sie
natürlich auch schützen aber sie sind
natürlich nicht wirksam tatsächlich
gegen dieses corona videos aber man kann
sich natürlich grundsätzlich nicht
schützen auch unter umständen schon für
die nächste wintersaison
es wird ja immer betont dass vor allem
ältere menschen gefährdet sind aber ein
junger mensch mit vorerkrankungen kann
ja auch wirklich gefährdet seien es ist
richtig dass richtig es gibt eben diese
bestimmten vorerkrankungen vor allem vom
herz kreislauf system natürlich der
lunge gegebenenfalls auch
stoffwechselerkrankungen und das kann
natürlich auch junge menschen betreffen
die dann entsprechend auch gefährdet
sind gegen diesen erreger
wenn jemand diabetes hat oder auch
medikamente nehmen muss kortison oder
sonstige medikamente erzählt man dann
schon als risikopatient man sollte
zumindest mal vorsichtig sein denn es
ist da auch hier lernen die permanent
der zunge wissen noch nicht ganz genau
wirklich was die eigentliche
risikogruppen sein werden das muss man
erst schlussendlich
die pandemie oder die epidemie
fortgeschritten ist analysieren das
können wir noch nicht sagen also man
kann nur raten vorsichtig zu sein
eine frage haben wir noch von einem
zuschauer warum warum haben die leute
alles auf die antwort von gerona bewusst
sagt ja der kbs immunsystem hat der
dürfte nicht erkranken
das ist leider nichts offensichtlich ja
so dass die meisten die ja jetzt den
krankenhäusern behandelt werden
natürlich im prinzip zwar entsprechende
vorerkrankungen beziehungsweise in
risikopatienten sind aber das hat
natürlich mit dem immunsystem zunächst
nichts zu suchen das sind eben ältere
patienten die unter umständen eben auch
andere grunderkrankungen haben zum
beispiel als kreislauf erkrankung und
die sind besonders betroffen
dank professor blase für diese
informationen mehr danke dass sie bei
uns man die herausforderungen für die
nächsten tage sind auch in dieser
sendung wieder mal deutlich geworden da
kommt was auf uns zu was uns an grenzen
bringen wird mit panikmache hat das
alles nichts zu tun
panik ist tatsächlich nicht angesagt
vorsicht und einsicht aber umso mehr
das war es von uns für heute weitere
informationen und alle aktuellen
entwicklungen bekommen sie auf der heute
app und der zdf mediathek hier folgt
jetzt aktenzeichen xy
mach es gut und ihnen allen noch einen
schönen
corona global wie das virus die welt
verändert
auslandsjournal spezial heute abend
endstation libyen das mittelmeer ist
keine männer